[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits amis hop hop hop hop
aujourd'hui le bon propos roulait bien
joyeux ce soir nounours patron j'ai avec
moi toutes mes économies
il ne faut le dire à personne qui a
raison sois prudent soyez sans crainte
au porte bonheur on le cheval aux
bobos
[Musique]
messieurs donnez moi aussi at il dit
et voilà ma ptite dame c'est pour votre
garçon oui monsieur
c'est pour moi que tu étais bill ça fait
combien vingt mille francs
c'est pas cher et demi où je sèche est
en marche on oui mais ciel après que
voulez-vous hd ça dépend souvent du goût
[Musique]
de tous des gâteaux des bonbons des
truies en couleur et d'ibiza fiore des
bateaux de tous vous vendez des bateaux
oui monsieur idée bout ça m'intéresse
j'aimerais un bateau pour faire des
voyages on
d'accord vous verrez ce toi cher il faut
compter combien pour rabobank
6 francs au un instant je vais regarder
si j'ai assez d'argent
mais monsieur m vous allez être contents
à chamonix
[Musique]
à
2 ou
tenues voilà sinon merci monsieur
mais manque une pièce ce matin
soudainement
[Musique]
[Rires]
cet ami bois
toutes mes économies pour un morceau de
bois alors alors mais où sont-ils pas
dessus
[Musique]
rendez moi mon argent je n'en veux pas
de votre bateau
[Musique]
ils magasins fermés c'est du vol je m'en
vais porter plainte à mon patron c'est
un scandale non c'est le lot
des cds pas là elles sont pas belles et
qu'elles ne nous assure même pas un
chocolat offre au mieux de la lui rendre
d'accord ou les lui rendre à damas
comme un bien petit joueur
[Musique]
que se passe-t-il nounours tu n'as pas
l'air content au salon alors regardez
patron un morceau de bois ils m'ont
vendu sa à la place d'un bateau et je
leur ai donné toutes mes économies je
porte plainte
aux portes plein allons calme toi je
suis certain que demain tout va
s'arranger mais une prochaine fois tu
devras être plus prudent bonne nuit les
enfants
fêtes de bourg eux
[Musique]